trying to find a comfortable positions
welcome back to another episode of trash
today's time corner and once again I'm
joined by the boys joying on yes we are
doing our last started last podcast
episode in uh London
yeah sad to be going this is such a nice
set yeah definitely um well most well
produced set definitely yeah we've had a
lot of well-produced sets but this one
is uh on another level I'd say yeah
you're gonna be Saturday
oh my god oh we've got everything here
you have to share them because we didn't
utilize it but you got to do the the
wrestling entrance because oh yeah so
there's a there's this door here where I
guess can uh enter from wait let me let
me enter from there come on Joe I'll do
like a I'll do like a little yeah all
right all right tell us when you're
ready Jay
hailing from Australia it's the man
himself from down underage the anime man
I saw it
the worst takes in all of Australia he's
come on to defend himself
okay don't break the say that's Connor's
job there we go there we go we don't
have insurance guys come on yes so since
the anime man you're coming on the
podcast today
first time is this your first time yes
I mean so we've got like some actual
like interesting questions I feel from
the VIP section of like our tour you
know so to explain uh in every show we
do we had like an hour kind of like VIP
q a and sometimes you can kind of expect
what questions would be asked I think we
had a bet on in the Germany show about
uh how many questions it would take to
ask me about my opinions on breads
because every single show came up yeah
yeah uh but I think I feel like one
interesting question we actually got was
someone actually asked uh what are the
seven wonders of anime and then we
started answering it and then we
realized that uh we should probably stop
because we were getting into an argument
about it and we had we had a show to do
the next day no we're going to show you
the next hour sorry so we were just like
yeah
are we counting in manga and this was
strictly anime oh
you don't read manga Connor so why would
that play why would that
okay
so you're
you you did a dramatic pause to call me
out you're like well Connor does it
[__] matter if you're dumb
why would it would it affect your eyes
no absolutely because like if we're
talking if we're including Margaret like
berserk is up there but if it's not it's
it's oh that is sure
to clarify that right now for the
audience so they're like why wasn't this
thing on there it's like because okay
here's here's the thing I've always
noticed about the difference between
give me a yes or a no God okay the
answer is no okay okay have you noticed
this about like the manga Community
where no one can agree on what the best
anime is but in terms of like the goaded
mangas it's always [__] Vagabond
berserk okay
slam dunk you know it's always like the
same 10 manga they get I guess mentioned
I'm not sure I'm glad we got that out of
the way right now yeah so no longer just
strictly number one hit me out all right
my hero action
shut the [__] up because nothing has
United people in hating so much you know
I just think that I thought it was the
Dragon Ball fans for the longest time
can we get this clear first and foremost
like what are the like the credentials
for it to be considered like the Seven
Wonders like does it have to be like
okay actually going Beyond anime what
are the actual seven wonders of the
world can you guys can you guys name the
seven wonders of the world one of them
is the pyramids I'm getting that one
right now
Stonehenge I don't know
that is not a [__] one [__] off okay
hold on let's just say let's [__] it up
just a pile of rocks with the Great Wall
um
of course this is more than seven yeah
that's that's definitely more than seven
the new Seven Wonders oh yeah there's
like the old seven wonders of the world
and the new Seven Wonders the whole
Seven Wonders is [__] dumb right yeah
I prefer Mount Rushmore as an allegory
because very it's a lot more intense you
see faces as a Wonder well there's like
a it's like a description like obviously
there's a foreign
you'd be like no no actually Mount
Rushville is the best one though I mean
I mean I won't say Mount Rushmore is
very impressive how the [__] did they
build that you know if you're trying to
do that now we'd be like sorry guys the
hidden Leaf Village there kind of better
you know yeah I can't believe it okay
when we say Seven Wonders what we mean
is like just the seven most greatest or
influential yeah we've got to get the
definition clear right like are we
talking about like seven like you know
influential anime
commercially viable because each of the
wonders in our real world they all do
something different so I think an anime
could be up there for being influential
but an anime could also be up there for
just being the like they're going yeah
and maybe one of them is uh has done
something or inspired a bunch yeah I
mean clearly we just searched up Seven
Wonders
not even the the internet can figure out
what a wonder is so I guess we just go
by there's an anime News Network with
seven wonders of anime
of the anime world
yeah they actually just did locations in
anime okay that's cool that's a cool
idea but we're not gonna do that we're
not going to do that no we do not know
locations maybe controversial opinion I
don't think Astro Boy should be on there
yes it [__]
Joey come on come on come on yes yes I
am serious I need to hear your reasoning
though I mean yeah kind of like it's
like it's like being like oh yeah uh top
10 film The Citizen Kane number two it's
like okay
okay we get it we're not talking about
that we want something excited yeah no
no one gets like so excited not every
wonder of the world is exciting yes they
are very exciting the point of the Seven
Wonders of the World at least like my
kind of personal definition is like it's
on everyone's like Bucket List Right of
places you need to see uh before before
you kick the bucket right you don't need
to see it you don't need to see Astro
Boy Yes it started animation foreign
[Music]
because it's such a we're doing a
podcast here we're trying to be
entertaining and I feel like it's boring
okay let's just [__] add my hero
Academia then how about that's at it how
about that dude all my
sexy yes
you want skinny version or you want
buffers yeah you can get either the
stuff that uh Endeavor has done for
Daddy Issues change the game like that's
they progressed they've been arrested
okay proves that Daddy issue is not a
gender specific yeah you know yeah sure
very very Progressive guys
yeah I just think that if we put Astro
Boy it's kind of you know okay fine
let's not put Astro Boy then would you
put Astro Boy on abso [__] lutely
because if we wouldn't be [__] but
then we're gonna have a list that's like
every old thing not necessarily I think
Astro Boy is the only like old school
anime that I would include on the Seven
Wonders personally [__] off
personally okay let's decide right now
we're only gonna agree to one old anime
okay what's what's your definition of
all like before the 90s before the 90s
80s 70s 60s right yeah okay if there was
one what would you pick probably
something probably it's probably got to
be like mobile sugandam right like I
guess we could put multiple Gundam
Gundams up there I mean Gundam Gundam is
still I came to this day that has like
its lineage has gone like you know since
the beginning Gundam and it still goes
on to this day okay are we including
movies
if that's the case then I agree with
Connor I think Akira should be up there
even though I know you don't write it
okay let's let's put it on the maybe
list okay let's see if we can think of
uh like you know I agree with is there
something we all agree on I agree with
you on Gundam okay uh one one I would
like so the first thing that absolutely
comes to mind for me yeah is Evangelion
Evangelion I think is the very
definition of the anime that's you know
like I should have put Gundam on sorry
I'd rather put Gundam on I feel like
Gundam makes more sense what is gonna
make more sense uh Evangelion is just
sad Gundam right more depressed I can't
believe you just said it's like it's
listen it's just listen Gundam is if
we're talking influential it's pretty
like the most in terms of and I'm happy
to agree with that no man uh if it
wasn't for mazinga Zed uh Gundam
wouldn't be here so yeah how many
seasons does mazingazette have it's like
two I think yeah so I mean I I feel like
Gundam has way more I think is always
also has a lineage that goes on to I
think yeah but I feel like we've got to
talk like pop culture relevance as well
and if we're talking that um I mean look
at how many fighters like in in terms of
Pop Culture reference in Japan I would
argue Ava is [__] up there I mean it
to me it's like the influence is had on
kind of like merchandising right because
that's just that's just because the Ava
team was just like they understood
marketing right Gundam Gundam was like
okay you know we'll make the gunplas and
those are still like those huge [__]
like yeah but with Ava it was like let's
put all of our characters on [__]
yeah that's because of the marketing
team not because of the anime I don't
[__] watch the single gun right I
just Evangelion is super popular only
really in Japan to that level whereas
Gundam is globally known on such a more
wider scale and also I feel guys
own amongst like different generational
like groups you know also like this
might be a hot take but I think it's
more important that an anime fan watches
Ava than an anime fan watches Gundam and
I know I've probably pissed off all the
gundam fans I mean I think that's fair I
think I think Ava is just such it's it's
like such a turning point for like the
anime kind of like industry as a whole
um you don't need to like Ava but I feel
like everyone needs to experience it at
least once just to have an opinion on it
there's a reason why Ava aired and
[__] I think 1995 or 1997 I can't
remember the exact year and it's like
been over 20 years and we are still
discussing it you know okay yeah let's
get a good idea then because so we we
have a Google search of top 10 most
influential anime pulled up so let's see
what Google says is the top 10 and then
we can kind of go from there number one
is Akira okay all right it is not the
number one most influential
yeah
number one okay what's number two
thank you oh my god wow influential is a
an important term yeah yeah all right
what's number three
[Music]
all right number four
Pokemon
[Music]
um
the game yes I would I wouldn't
necessarily say the anime it's hard to
it's hard to like boil Pokemon down to
its anime because it's just like a
[__] multimedia franchise yeah it's
kind of been stuck in like the Saturday
car Saturday morning cartoon Loop yeah
it's kind of like it's kind of like
putting Hello Kitty on there you know
like is it influential is it iconic yes
but is it something that deserves to be
on a list like this I'm not sure all
right number five number five nalska
wow yeah okay it is my favorite film but
I personally wouldn't put it on there
this is just like dude this is the most
generic ass safe list ever yeah yeah go
down all right number six
okay okay there we go
even I don't know how much money does
Gundam make a year of selling Gundam
tickets it must be like like a stupid
half of the Japanese economy I mean I
think I think gundam model kits make
more money than the Dragon Ball
franchise absolutely yeah I wouldn't be
surprised by that yeah I'm not surprised
one thing I find interesting as I swear
I know more people that are into model
kits and just have only seen like one
gun okay or are not even a guy okay okay
131.3 billion yen in sales over the past
year yeah so basically one billion
dollars here's what I'm thinking guys I
think we need to separate this into
genres because I think we need like the
Mount Rushmore or the genre up here okay
so I feel like Gundam we're cornered the
mecca one right you know what I mean
well the remaining ones were Sailor Moon
and Evangelion okay oh okay I mean yeah
I mean I understand Evangelion uh I I
think Gundam is more influential but I
guess it's up to us what we decided yeah
uh all right all right all right guys
guys all right hear me out hear me out
okay because Dragon Ball we've already
we've just all said the dragon balls up
there right okay I would say
in this particular moment I think Dragon
Ball is definitely up there
can I make something can I say something
that might be controversial okay what
now go give it 20 years or maybe even
like 15 years do you think that more
people are going to be talking and
remembering the end of one piece then
then Dragon Ball because Dragon Ball was
obviously our era but if you're assuming
one piece is going to end it is good
that's the thing though that's the thing
it is going to end one piece will be
ending within the next 10 years I think
okay okay okay okay
but like he he sees that the kind of guy
who won't let it quit yeah no no I mean
it's it's like maybe okay okay I feel
that's a great question but I feel the
comparison is also slightly unfair
because roughly you know like whenever
the [__] one piece ends like let's say
in the next five years of One Piece ends
right like five years from now or
already even now compared to when Dragon
Ball ended right the landscape of the
anime fan random internationally has
just exploded right like the the like
you know when whenever Dragon Ball ended
I don't even remember when it was but
like you know when that ended the
especially the international anime
Community was not as like heavily
invested or was like openly talking
about anime yeah in the same way that
they are talking about it today yeah
right so I feel that comparison is
slightly unfair and to answer your
question more people will be talking
about one piece just because it's going
to end in a period where people are
[__] like it's like Dragon Ball never
got to the point where it was trending
on Twitter no no you know but like okay
so okay like here's like my like
thinking around this because obviously
Dragon Ball [__] Global sensation
hugely influential now we uh this is
something that got many people into
anime
um but I think we're gonna see something
interesting when one piece comes to an
end because it's going to be the very
first globally popular franchise because
one piece somehow is only getting more
and more popular now as has gone on
um it's going to be a show that has gone
on for like 20 30 years and people will
have grown up one piece and seen it come
to his conclusion and I think the
[__] power of that when it ends is
something that I can't think of another
franchise that will like come close to
grasping that kind of power where you
have a whole generation of anime fans
now that are going to grow up see one
piece come to its conclusion and that's
going to be the most important like kind
of show that's stuck with them in their
lives I mean I guess like Naruto kind of
got close in that sense but you can't we
can't decide the the the Wonders based
on what could happen it might be a new
Wonder it might be a new one I just feel
like yeah one piece hasn't ended so he
can't have that confidence yeah yeah
yeah okay so right now right now Dragon
Ball fans you have the throne so who's
to say they want [__] like boruto
that [__] you know what I mean they'll
be like yeah
Luffy had a kid and uh the thing is that
he's made of stone instead of rubber
and it's called Rock piece
like I I just dude I just feel like one
piece they'll never let it die I feel
like they're gonna do something with it
you know what I mean yeah I mean they're
already like doing you know like
spin-off like side character base like
manga series and stuff like that yeah I
mean they did they did a whole one for
Ace and like his backstory yeah [__] me
yeah illustrated by the uh guy who made
Dr CERN
which is actually really good I would
recommend it okay okay I I didn't know
that was a thing
even I read that yeah yeah okay okay so
like all right yeah they're probably
gonna end up doing that but as of right
now we can't really yeah that's the
other thing we should figure out
like is currently ongoing series
acceptable to be put into the mount rush
I think if they've had the big enough
impact okay yeah but I think one I think
one piece hasn't had the same effect as
Dragon Ball not yet but I think I think
if I think as there might be a point in
the future where it does have the same
impacts to like a generation
maybe even more yeah I think it's I
think it's like it's like the same level
honestly right now yeah um
anything good in like 10 years and I
still can't I haven't watched anything
in 10 years by the way I don't know I'm
just judging that based off of the fact
that nobody has mentioned that anything
Dragon Ball recently is good to me no
the Broly movie was good oh I've heard
that okay so okay if we're talking in
terms then do you feel like Akira
deserves to be on the more than like no
I just want to say it so that my ass is
covered when Akira fans come for this
yeah I mean I was like guys I tried it I
okay I personally only thing yes I think
Akira deserves to be on there more than
Spirited Away right just purely because
like oh yeah I just want to give him any
credit well I mean look as much as I
love Spirited Away like and you know it
did win an Oscar and everything but like
I think just like the pure impact of
Akira not just within the anime fandom
but like outside the anime fandom was
just like [__] insane like there are
so many people where you'd be like you
would never associate with liking anime
or knowing anything about anime who are
like yeah Akira first of all boss baby
was nominated for an Oscar so I feel
like using Oscars as a base also Shrek
won an Oscar which is great yeah
this is kind of ballpark everywhere the
boss baby got nominated yeah Oscars yeah
I feel like that's not a good metric but
um yeah and I'm sure more anime would
have got the nominated of course back
then if they weren't so kind of closed
off too far okay if you don't think
Akira should be up there then what if if
you had to pick a movie yeah okay we
agree we have to pick one movie was it
let's let's see what you guys feel about
if you had to pick one anime movie to be
on the Mount Rushmore which would it be
I would pick a cure
yeah probably be Akira I mean we're
picking between the camera on the first
time
hear me out guys actually go to the
actually change the game the one with me
too where he's like I am too strong
Pikachu crying hear me out guys Demon
Slayer
the top grossing anime movie of all time
hello the metrics don't lie hello data
doesn't care about your feelings Joey
called inflation okay who's making more
money
but yeah okay if we're doing movies
there's only gonna be one there's
there's only like two options it's
either gonna be a Ghibli movie or a
Kiara and I am lukewarm on both so I
yeah I don't know strong feelings about
anime movies I just don't care for them
I mean my favorite anime movies are like
satoshikon movies but unfortunately
that's like the more when you go more
down into like the rabbit hole Yeah
that's like the Citizen Kane of the
anime world yeah yeah
no it's like page three of IMDb
um what other genres are we missing so
we've done Shonen did we agree on a
movie or not yeah yeah okay we actually
agree on a camera now right we've got
Kyra so we got Dragon Ball and Akira
right now and we couldn't agree on a
Mecca one if you guys really it's
between Gundam and Ava if you really if
you guys really really want it I'll give
it okay Mecca I feel is like you know
that is like very uniquely anime I feel
you know so I feel like one of them has
to be up there yeah the question is
which one okay okay but here's in this
specific kind of like scenario
and this specific scenario
um I'm I don't think Ava should be in
the mecca category yeah
it's kind of this is kind of more like
you know especially anyone both on there
sorry are you saying you want both of
them
and we can stop taking stuff out and put
it yeah yeah I do want both on there do
you agree that Astro Boy was up there no
no no okay no because we because we
already have four on the list now we've
gone to me Ava Akira and uh what's the
fourth uh Pokemon Neptune nice
um
okay everything we've listed is pretty
old even though we said we weren't going
to put old anime on there
we have not put a new one the newest one
is actually an Ava is there a new anime
you guys have put on there
get the [__] down [__]
get Gojo's face off of like [__] that
Mount Rushmore man listen there's a
reason why everyone loves it
um I don't know new anime
like within the past decade
I mean maybe
uh
this is when it gets hard yeah we only
have three [__] slots left on the
stupid list well we can we can change
things around we can change things
around
is there any other nominations you want
to bring up corner would you like to
bring up Jojo I was thinking of hentai
but I wish to do it as hentai Seven
Wonders later
that's also an idea we can do later yeah
um I mean JoJo's could be up there but
it's for very different reasons than any
of the other ones I feel like JoJo's
kind of been like the Pinnacle of weird
art style having its own carving its own
Niche and kind of pushing a very weird
side of anime forward uh right and as
well as the impact on the fandom at
least in the west and also in Japan I
mean as well yeah and JoJo is just so
it's Jojo
yeah do you feel like Attack on Titan
should be up there
I think it's done yeah it depends
because I don't know the ending yet so
it really depends on how it's gonna end
yeah you know I mean I feel like
it probably oh my God I mean if it ends
within the next five years and they stop
[__] November okay finally yeah I
think
it probably does
but it's kind of hard it feels weird
putting it on I don't know why it feels
weird why does it feel weird putting it
on because one hasn't ended yet and two
we don't know the true impact of Attack
on Titan yet is it going to be something
like Breaking Bad where we still meme on
it uh like [__] 10 years down the
line probably will it still have
cultural significance it's hard to tell
it's gonna be a really [__] fun show
to go back and watch all the way through
again I and I've yeah I've been watching
it seasonally yeah yeah for my entire
life so it's gonna be fun to be able to
watch it back to back yeah yeah oh it
was great when I showed Sydney Attack on
Titan because she had somehow never seen
Attack on Titan uh just watching it like
binge watching it seasonally uh like
each season and just seeing how the show
has evolved was just like oh I forgot
how [__] good it was uh especially
now that when we the way it's being
released now you forget how hype and how
much has been built up and how much the
story just like interconnects together
sure uh and how much was foreshadowed
it's it was like a pleasure to to watch
it's just crazy that it came out 10
that's what blows my mind the most yeah
um yeah I don't know I feel like
other anime that could be up there I
feel like maybe it just doesn't feel
right to put it up there yet I feel like
I probably if we had this conversation
in four years it definitely would yeah
but I feel like we can do better all
right they're not I got a new nomination
okay Sailor Moon that's
that's just my childhood [__] you that's
just such a are you guys gonna make a
top 10 anime list of all time
revolutionize the Shoujo genre
revolutionize the magical girl genre did
you make it it did yeah so I mean yeah
so it should be up there
yeah can we can we fact check what the
first magical girl anime is
it's not Sailor Moon but it's definitely
popularized popularized it at least to
the West yeah it's just
Brotherhood
sword online
we are talking about influential anime
no right anime that has influenced the
industry we're not putting Astro Boy on
there shut the [__] up
anything about influence okay look I do
not want to hear that word come from
your mouth look look at how many isekai
area uh anime are airing right now how
much it's like gone it's a fan it's it
you say it's a fact people have been
saying this and sword art online and
it's still yet to die in fact it's still
[__] stronger than ever what started
it because of people like you keep
watching their eyes there what
popularized it so what else let's just
[__] put Goblin Slayer
revolutionizing NTR for goblins player
would not exist without Sword Art Online
Game No Life on the list as well because
that inspired a bunch of stuff too oh
yeah let's do that again okay let's put
a redo over here inspiring degeneracy
okay serious one though yeah
what do you guys think about Cowboy
bebot no no no no no no no no no just
thinking purely from the influence in
the west I know like in Japan Cowboy
Bebop wasn't as big but it was a it was
a propagator for anime in the West in
the 90s I agree but I think like death
note did more for for Western anime
is way more popular seeing Cowboy
bebop's influence has been dying uh with
every kind of like year that passes by
yes it was one of the first anime that
kind of like we all saw on television
um I don't see that [__] on television I
think Death Note had more influence than
me I agree I think definite had more
influence especially in the modern anime
era yeah it's crazy thank God obviously
people look at Cowboy people with more
like critical claim
um but yeah I I don't know if I would
put it on uh Elle's theme alone is more
influenced yeah
I'm giving this Cavalry off slander one
actual strong Contender I want to put on
even though people might not talk about
it too much
um nowadays uh Harry suzumia
it it was definitely uh it did
popularize the lion novel okay okay let
it won yes it popularized light novel
adaptations which which I argue is the
most popular adaptations we get in anime
there are more like normal applications
and I think manga adaptations or anime
Originals there are uh and you know how
are he popularized it and if I needed to
name an anime that's
epitomized mid-2000s anime culture it is
[__] Harry it's Harry or Lucky Star
you are you a half right gone you said
mid anime and you're right anime fans
I think I I would genuinely put Harry on
there because it is such a time capsule
of like the the anime climate of its
time every time capsule it belongs in
the past no one talks about it nowadays
I'm
yeah as much I kind of agree with Connor
like as much as I [__] love Harry and
like the that climate of the mid-2000s
anime world like it is a hard show to
sell to someone today yeah same thing
with Lucky Star [__] love Lucky Star
but I would not recommend it to people
today lucky stars hear me out for
changing the cosplay game Danganronpa
hear me out just single-handedly making
sure cosplay is always the same
I remember when junko cosplayers were
like everywhere
oh yandere simulator
if we are we have to put elephant lean
on there yeah
um okay so we have four we need to pick
one to go on we're gonna add sun to this
list okay I still think we should put
Sailor Moon on there yeah well yeah like
you say oh it's a boring choice but hey
it revolutionized so many genres it
popularized anime in the west especially
for a female audience we've literally
made an anime news network list so far
I'm just saying are we cool with that
you know what maybe they're right yeah
for once in their lives maybe they're
right you ever thought about that
one at least like posted we've got a
spicy one on here come on I'm I I mean
I'm saying how are heels
I have made my case
all right make a better case and name me
name me one that deserves to be on there
more than either of the ones on Death
Note entirely Death Note pop culture
impact alone Death Note crushes them
both uh not in Japan not to mention uh
Willem Dafoe uh who might I remind you
is notoriously a large penis uh who also
are the people who like that
that's true by the way but it's a true
fact Google it don't I don't look at
pictures they don't exist I tried uh um
I in Japan actually in Japan too there's
no Hara he's using me a musical there's
a death or a musical
you can watch it in London yeah I know
all right there is one of the first
penis was so large that after the
filming of the 2009 psychological
Thriller Antichrist the director had to
cut the scene would defrost actual penis
and reshoot it with a body tell because
it was so large that everyone in the
room was confused
it is my favorite fact that he has an
extreme thank you damn that's
interesting
so would you say that Death Note
deserves Beyond there more than Full
Metal Alchemist yes yeah
I think that Death Note gen like uh
memes aside now is actually is more
influential more spoken about still to
this day than a lot of these shows and
also I think it was a banger of a show I
think I think it was a ton of memes I
think what Death Note did as well that
was really influential was that it kind
of uh made I guess like the whole
Thriller anime cool it made the whole
Thriller
made cool you can you like death note
finally gave us an anime that allowed
you to recommend anime people yeah it
may it made it made the darker side of
anime more accessible yeah
it made you uh more likely to get
[__] bullied for having a [__]
death note
I just [__] watch it what the [__]
yeah all know everyone who wants that
[__] in the mid-2000 was like I'm gonna
get one myself and then take it to a kid
take your name in my death note I mean
we're like okay
I think you're actually clowning if you
think the Death Note had less impact
than Harry I'm just okay it's because I
think Death Note definitely had you know
was more popular in terms of like the
widely I think Harry was just more
influential in terms like the shaping
the kind of landscape value we already
have so many of this these kind of picks
on our list let's mix it up a little bit
mix it up a little bit we're not picking
let's not pick the most influential
let's pick like something
because otherwise we would just pick
Astro Boy and Astro boys well that's why
I said we should put up we're trying to
pick like the Seven Wonders we're
marking all stuff influential is one of
the points I think yeah yeah but it
shouldn't be the only thing we're
considering yeah and I think that it
should be saying that like it's it's an
anime that you kind of have to
experience and watch or uh to like be
considered an anime fan I think that is
one of those Animes
in that definition why is Fullmetal
Alchemist not on there who's gone hasn't
watched it God has a whole career
talking about anime
[__] you got me there this is this man's
job to watch anime and he hasn't watched
Fullmetal Alchemist and he's doing fine
so I mean that's true and Full Metal
Alchemist I think
almost it's kind of like
it's such a weird way to describe it I
feel like it we needed a constant number
one and we've just all agreed that it's
good enough to be number one but I think
a lot of people wouldn't actually say
it's their favorite no but I think we
just we like having these constants in
our lives and I think everyone gets a
little bit of comfort from being like
yes Fullmetal Alchemist is it's the safe
choice is a very respectable choice that
we all agree and we all keep for some
reason keeping it at number one yeah uh
because we feel like the story is very
concise it's very well told and very
enjoyable okay in in that it's like a
it's like a measurement of unit but like
you have a we have the meter somewhere
locked away in France okay if we're
going by that logic then what would you
say other than death note or full metal
what would you say is like another anime
that you would be like okay if you if
you want to get into anime this is the
one that you have to watch
that's a great question
um I mean because then we can use that
as a metric to figure out like okay
which one of them should be I'd say
Attack on Titan that's like yeah that's
my go-to-blind anime recommendation if I
don't know if I know nothing about the
person because yeah this is because
unfortunately anime has this issue where
if people don't watch anime they have
preconceived notions of what
animation is and it's for children's and
yeah yeah yeah so the reason why often
that's narrative I can get recommended
is because they're a lot more serious a
lot darker and it's a lot it's a great
way of kind of showing someone want a
great show but also two showing them hey
this whole genre has a vast variety of
uh different topics and yeah some of it
is childish yeah there are a lot of
really mature shows and Stories being
told yeah the whole level of stuff like
you know I know it's a [__] meme at
this point it's like Breaking Bad but
you know storytelling that like is I
think like at the same kind of maturity
yeah yeah no I I agree I think Titan
does that so then do we agree in that
case then that a tag on time should be
up there yeah I mean I'm happy to put it
up there but I did just feel a little
like too soon but I mean yeah I mean if
if we're going something like this I I I
want to like restate my uh starts on one
piece then oh man I think
oh that's really epic just balding in
that one huh yeah I mean one piece seems
to be like seems to be the anime that
it's kind of like the anime that
everyone needs to be at least have like
some kind of opinion on now you know
it's it's everyone needs to be up to
date or you need an opinion on like what
we're gonna do that we should get rid of
Dragon Ball
I'll agree to put it on if we are the
Dragon Ball I mean I'll do it just to
spy Dragon Ball fans you know okay so
we're replacing Dragon Ball with one
piece I'm happy to do that because I
don't like Dragon Ball and I've been
very vocal about that okay I think
Dragon Ball is Iconic for many reasons
yeah uh mannequins of the [__] spiky
hair uh in that outline [__]
everyone knows Goku yeah
ah actually I can't do it I can't do it
I can't do you can't do it I I mean the
it's it's less of Dragon Ball and it's
more just like the idea of Dragon Ball
you know the idea like it's too iconic
yeah it's it's it's too iconic and we
just can't put them both on the list I
think I occupy the same space yeah I
think I think our Judgment of Dragon
Ball has purely been clouded by the fans
because because if you separate the show
from the fan base the show is [__]
fantastic yeah and highly influential
and it's great fun really easy to get
into and the comments of this on this
episode I mean nuclear yeah I can't wait
um okay I had something and I forgot it
now this episode is sponsored by ship
station the holiday season is just
around the corner and if you own any
kind of e-commerce business like I do
for example look at this guy of course
he owns an e-commerce the rush is
absolutely real but you can prepare your
e-commerce business for the holiday rush
now just just by using ship station
whether you're shipping from your house
or your Warehouse shipstation can help
increase your profitability you can save
time automating your shipping and
returns in the shipstation dashboard and
key costs down with industry-leading
carrier discounts while your holiday
orders roll in with shipstation there's
a free trial and a quick setup to help
you get going as a business owner Joey's
time is valuable he needs to sell some
carpets right now God damn it I worship
station it's so easy to use he can save
all the time he needs you can also
easily automate shipping tasks to manage
orders in one simple dashboard and not
just that you can manage order's print
labels compare rates optimize every
shipment and automate delivery
notifications it can pretty much do
everything gym station's robust
automations and Reporting May scaling
easy and as your business grows you can
save thousands on shipping costs plus
you get industry-leading discounted
rates from USPS UPS DHL and Global posts
get discounts up to 84 84 USPS and UPS
rates so set up your business for the
holiday season success with ship station
go to shipstation.com and use code trash
today to sign up for us free 60-day
trial don't say that again that's
shipstation.com code trash out of the
episode all right hear me out we've
played it safe in some of the genres all
right okay no not domestic girlfriend or
girlfriend you can say or email I'm
gonna kill you a big [__] part of the
anime culture is the [__] degenerates
right it is it is a massive it is
amazing yeah edgy shows okay
High School DxD
I think maybe High School
I'm not even see I I would have said
High School the day yeah
I was like I don't know if I like I
don't know if it's just me or my
generation I remember like High School
of the Dead but definitely up there if I
were to like think of what show started
like the rabbit hole down like High
School of the Dead it took an entire
generation of anime watches it was like
oh [__] and there were two two moments
in particular that stand out to me uh
the two Canon events in my life one was
watching High School of the Dead and the
second was the toothbrush scene in
Nissan
that like that to me it just it started
at different times to be the horny list
instead the morning I could do a whole
Mount Rushmore
but I'm saying it's a big part of the
anime Community yes God forbid I don't
mean to use whatever Network I'm not
gonna put these [__] jokes if we're
gonna put monogatar series on there I
ain't complaining I don't think
monogatari deserves to be on there it's
it's to me so Jerry was like
it would be an honor to put High School
High School of the Dead I think yeah
because if we're talking especially like
mid-2000s anime like that was a show
that a everyone watched B everyone was
like I think pleasantly surprised
watching as well because I think a lot
of people again went into high school
today thinking oh it's a zombie anime
and then they were like why is my dick
hard so you know I think just like
subverting expectations and then also
just being one of the show that so
almost memed to the point where like you
couldn't not be like at the time be go
up to someone and be like have you
watched high school they're dead it's
it's you kind of have to watch it it's a
show that not many people like bring up
often but whenever you do everyone only
has positive things to say about it even
though it's it's one where you're just
like oh I definitely don't want my mom
to see this but as soon as you bring it
up if they're like yo that was [__]
lit man yeah it was [__] totally
great
so if we want to be different because
that's what you want right
no I just uh yeah I mean High School dxt
is High School DxD is also up there so
it's like high school the dead sorry
yeah I think they both have D's in them
High School
um yeah I mean I think it's it's a valid
argument uh I think we can do better
though
do better love you know
[__] I mean it was influential the OG
king of harems man it was influenced the
OG king of Arabs what can I say like no
mine have aged well at least the anime
hasn't but you know it's the manga's age
Walter well the manga has age well I'm
trying to think I'm sure she didn't say
Gintama Jerry I thought you're right but
I guess it's not okay yeah as much as I
love Gintama and it's like always ranked
highly on my anime list it's just it's
it's a difficult it's a difficult anime
to get people into I feel because I feel
guintama is an anime for anime fans you
know what I watch four episodes I had a
hard time kind of getting into it yeah
it's it's very like you either don't get
it at all or you are absolutely in love
with it you know there's no in the
middle all right influential I think uh
Kaiju because it made a generation of
gambling addicts uh and that certainly
influenced their lives because they make
gambling really cool all right deadly
don't you mean don't you mean yeah no oh
taiji is the better gambling anime and
everyone knows it and anyone who says
[__] wrong kakiguri was highly
influential it was so interesting people
are still cosplaying you maker yeah yeah
because it's easy you because you can
buy it on Amazon for 10 bucks you look
up like Tick Tock cosplay videos and
it's like filled with you maker because
it's ten dollars yeah because you can
get a red school outfit that fits in a
black wig it's too easy to do yeah that
that show is capital B for boring dude
yeah it's like what the men watch when
they want to gamble but kaiji is like
can I use one of those shows it's not
gonna be on there by the way yeah but
yeah but that's the thing Angie is the
better anime is definitely the better
anime but it's one of those shows where
it's like only the people actually
watched it read it yeah you know what I
mean because it's [__] ugly and for
some reason they only released it in
720p yeah yeah this might just the
weirdest fact no other anime did this
but for some reason kaiji was like 720
people do yeah why I think one that in
in that vein then I think one that
almost gets like uh overshadowed by
shows like kaiji or uh kakiguri is like
death parade
but every person I know who has seen
that is like rated super highly That's
What I Call like a Hidden Gem no no yeah
kind of Hidden Gem but it's it's never
someone's favorite show it's always just
like someone's like 10th favorite show
you know it's not it's never the first
one that pops into someone's mind
um so okay I can't believe I'm about to
say this
no
I can't I cannot believe I'm about to
say this he said it but he said it ah my
way cute girls doing cute things that
was awesome as [__] that is you know a
massive part of anime culture if it
wasn't for K on Bocce The Rock wouldn't
be here
which fate do I put down guys I have to
pick one
also bankrupting half of Japan's Young
Generation look look without chaon we
wouldn't have people having the worst
[__] takes on Twitter using a [__]
anime anime cute anime girl profile okay
also the mid-2000s mobile movement was
all started from K on and that was like
everywhere before the Sakai thing came
in so what's on our list again we
haven't put anything on it Dragon Ball
Akira Gundam Ava and attacks and Attack
on Titan and Sailor Moon
um Okay so
I I just remembered like Ghost in the
Shell was also massively [__]
influential as well yeah that's true but
then the movie was kind of me yeah
yeah I know maybe you've got a definite
movie was fantastic with all the
duolumne
I mean he's so great all right all right
is there any other shows you guys would
like to bring up or shall we try and
start finalizing this list
um what about what about in the sports
genre
it's a it's pretty much gonna be only
slam dunk in terms of influential and
that's mostly the manga yeah
um there are influential like Sports
Anime like haikyuu
um Hajime Oppo is a fan favorite but I
don't think that's as influential but I
don't think I a Sports Anime
can stand on the same caliber as some of
the other shows uh uh crocodile basket
no
no I'm [__] with you uh freak on have
you heard of it
uh you're in a Yuri nice right guys
so good yeah your favorite anime yeah I
mean I mean I don't know it kind of
feels like the seventh one will be like
just like one of the presidents you
don't know Mount Rushmore
yeah well okay we got to think like what
other genre are we missing because so we
have like we obviously have our Shonen
we have our America
is there an influential romance anime
influential romance no I don't
um
no I don't I don't think there is planet
I mean I love it but it's not no no no
chaos no no ah cokius is also one of the
mega genres yeah it's kind of the mecca
genre and it's it's also kind of code
yes for me is also kind of in the same
places like death parade where it's like
people will Raider but it's never like
the number one yeah I feel like except
Charlie yeah I don't dance for furries
I'm encoded but I wouldn't put it I
still think JoJo could go on there
probably but it's kind of tough because
the the anime has had a lackluster
previous season yeah uh like
yeah I can't I can't are there any other
anime genres that were missing that's
you can think of Nabi
yeah we did mention this four I'm trying
to think if there's anything else
obvious
ly rom-coms that's like kind of like
there's there's no good comedy anime
that deserves to be up there
um I don't count Gintama get that [__]
away anime
horror anime that's not gonna be up
there
um so yeah I think we have our
nominations okay so let's start
finalizing it so I think we can all
agree
Akira yes uh
so far I think it's a little safe but
yeah okay so we so so far we have Akira
Gundam yeah Evangelion yeah uh Sailor
Moon Dragon Ball yeah uh what else is
there death note and Attack on Titan
wait we can talk about death and if
there's anything else if you want to um
I do think because this is this is
I'd rather put a cell world
I mean I I I'm I think out of everything
the one that I feel most strongly about
is actually Harry like I'm not putting
Harry on us yeah
[Music]
actually like Slice of Life or
psychological yeah I mean evangelion's
the psychological one slice of life I
think Slice of Life is hierarchy season
two
there's no way that you guys think Harry
belongs on there more than Death Note no
way I think in terms of influence no
influence we're considering everything
yeah considering everything like I think
I think Harry he brought on a bigger
movement than Death Note
on a Grand Design I think if we consider
everything harahi had a bigger impact on
anime because yes I think Death Note had
more fans but I think Harry he was as
popular as Death Note back in the day at
least when they were in Japan I think
hierarchy was more popular and I think
the thing that gives Harry The Edge is
just how it has popularized
um the way a whole different medium
that's getting adapted yeah uh for
better you know whether you like that
change or not it was the Catalyst for it
yeah one of the record I don't agree
with this yes
I think definite is much more
influential but hey yeah I don't see the
Google Trends Cooper Harry suzumia
versus death note on Google Trends
iPhone instant gratification all right
obviously death though it's going to be
higher because it's more normal it's
more normal yeah it's more for the
normies it's more normal more
influential some might say hey we don't
know the girl trying to come in favor
we I guess the audience can decide this
then uh I can't wait for hierarchy is
not an anime for non-anime fans that is
true I think it's quite limited I think
Death Note appeals to the masses no but
I think but I think in terms of the
general like change and movement that
are brought to the anime fandom and the
way that anime is like created and
marketed I think Harry he had more of an
influence than Death Note did Harry was
a Canon event for the anime industry
yeah like
yeah death note I think was only I think
Death Note was like propagated purely
because of all the other shows that it
came out alongside of especially during
Shonen Jump because that came out during
a golden period also I just feel like
kyota animation deserves a place on the
list
animation one of the most goaded anime
uh uh Studios of all time and I think I
think they deserve a place in their list
which would you prefer Harry or [__]
chaon
neither
make it a six wonders list yeah
actually there are only uh six wonders
in anime
I'm sorry
uh Death Note to Haruhi suzumir or just
yeah you put Harrow here yeah yeah yeah
you should come up just just how are you
well that was uh that was that was
pretty interesting yeah it's a pretty
good I can't wait for the comments yeah
yeah it's probably definitely got
drafted by [__] Harrow here death
notes on said Eighth Wonder of the anime
War
I rushed my case Yeah well yeah clearly
that's not even like that's that was
that's not even shocking that's United
Kingdom we do worldwide uh for the past
as far as it goes back
if we're doing [__] Google Trends
let's just name off the most popular
anime you know I'm sure oh let's see
there we go see Death Note constantly
more popular never been a point in time
I mean we're not we're not talking about
purely popularity unless you know in
that case
it is it is but that means uh we that
means we should put basically like
Naruto up there narrator over Naruto
then
you know we I'm pretty sure like you
know yeah literally picking all the
normal shirts Harry he was more popular
than Death Note at one point for one
month look at that at one point
July 2006 literally
came out
it was like all right you've had your
time
look at that beautiful well when did the
death or anime come out actually let's
go 2007. yeah so wait whilst it was like
the the manga was happening it was yeah
yeah I mean like death note was showing
and jump and uh pretty much any Sharon
jump show yeah or manga yeah you can you
can literally replace Death Note with
any Shonen Jump show from this period
and it'll probably be the same this
episode is sponsored by Mint mobile
turning your life away to a big wireless
provider is kind of like being trapped
on a roller coaster from Hell sure it
looked fun at first but they probably
threw in a free phone but now you can't
get off month after month of insane
Bill's and unexpected Thrills like
overage and surprise fees if that sounds
like your current big Wireless plan it's
time to get off that ride with mint
mobile for a limited time Wireless plans
for Mid mobile are just 15 a month
that's unlimited tax and data for just
15 a month honestly when we went to
America this year there were so many
Wireless plans and of everything I saw
mint mobile had the best deals which is
why I actually went with mint mobile
before we even got signed with them me
and mobile is here to rescue you with
premium Wireless plans for just 15 bucks
a month all say bye bye to your big
Wireless plans jaw dropping monthly
bills and unexpected overages all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mobile plan and bring
your phone number along with all your
existing contacts ditch big Wireless
with mint Mobile's limited time deal and
get premium wireless service for just 15
bucks a month 15 bucks a month that's
all it takes so to get your new
Unlimited Wireless plan which is 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com trash that's
mintmobile.com trash cut your wireless
bill to just 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com trash back to the episode
speaking of uh Seven Wonders though and
uh kind of like you know things on your
bucket list we've done a lot in life
right now we've
I I you know we've traveled to a lot of
places for sure
um do you have anything on your
anti-bucket list the [__] the [__] a
Nancy something that you've done once
and you're like I'm good never doing
that again uh going to France
[Laughter]
actually I'm I'm good actually I agree
with that I think we all agree with that
yeah specifically yeah
going to Paris specifically I do want to
go to France
is actually great yeah
how does it feel to be like I want to
any French people how does it feel to be
French how does it feel to be for any
French people watching uh to be French
and knowing that Paris has overtaken how
ever like the rest of at least Europe
views you guys well I think I think like
even non-parisian French people can
agree that like yeah Paris kind of
[__] sucks yeah anti-bucket list
honestly [__] Kyoto dude it is a
miserable experience to go into Kyoto
yeah I mean especially now that you know
the world's back to normal
Kyoto is what like when people come to
Japan like I want to go see it I'm like
yeah yeah you should you should see it
at least once yeah and never again uh it
is such a miserable time to go like
shoulder to shoulder with people yeah
like climbing up these stairs it's all
sweaty if it's so loud it's just it's
just way too touristy now right back to
the point where it's not fun yeah I
think the I think the biggest problem
with Kyoto is that even though it's
supposed to be this very like old part
of Japan traditional part of Japan where
you get to really like you know immerse
yourself in the history of the country
the fact that it is also at the same
time the most touristy spot in the world
is just like that disparity just like
kind of takes the magic out of it for me
yeah you know like again yeah like sure
if it's the first time coming to Japan
Kyoto go for it you know but once you're
there once you're done I think you're
good I don't know I feel like have you
been back to Kyoto since Taurus uh okay
I don't want to it is yeah yeah I I've
seen the pictures I see the crowds even
in places outside of Kyoto and I'm like
no I'm good especially I've been three
times since and the outskirts of Kyoto
are still amazing and lovely and really
good but my God the city Santos and the
touristy areas are miserable yeah yeah
definitely
um something for me uh uh I don't know I
don't know why this popped up
skateboarding I think I think I tried it
once
there's a list about going places no no
not going places it's a bucket list you
know the things you want to do things
you've tried once and you're like I'm
never trying that again when did when
did you skateboard you know when
skateboarding like it was when like
[__] Tony Hawks became a thing I like
everyone in school I tried skateboarding
and that craze became a thing and some
people you know stuck with it and I I
remember trying it once I tried to do an
ollie
um and I was just like my body is just
not built for skateboarding man I you
know sometimes you know some people just
have like a skater energy you know some
people are just like yeah built for this
type of things I I am like the opposite
of that man yeah I mean I did
skateboarding for a little bit when I
was young
um and like I could do like Ollie's and
like you know I I tried to do it you
definitely have skater energy
bro yes I could I could [__] see you
yeah yeah like that like I wasn't like
great at it I think I like landed a
kickflip once in my life uh after eating
[__] 30 times
um but like now that I am approaching 30
I I know my body is just like you don't
have to do this anymore yeah I don't
want skateboard because I'm everything
will break in my body yeah exactly
that's true as well yeah you know I
still want to do more snowboarding
um you did eat a lot of [__] that was
that was very very fun yeah I do want to
do more winter sports uh because I feel
like I didn't grow up with it
anti-bucket list yeah
um
what else is there because I usually
don't really do things unless I feel
like I'm going to want to do it again I
feel like you had an answer in Minecon
right because you made you brought this
question up was there something on your
mind that you thought was really funny
oh I don't know I just I think I I think
I I can't remember just because I think
I saw like a random Thread about this
and I was like oh that's pretty
interesting I've never heard of the term
anti-bucketness before like I think it's
yeah they probably just coined it I
think it's pretty yeah I've never heard
of that it's not a real thing would you
do bungee jumping again is that
something you do yeah that was fun that
was fun yeah I love the there was a
sensation when I was bungee jumping
where for like one second it kind of
felt like ah what if I just jumped off a
cliff
uh and you got to have that sensation
for like one second of just complete
like just falling yeah that was really
cool really trippy yeah
you fall faster than you think you would
oh yeah
um you fall so fast gravity is yeah
we're seeing it like POV POV or four
legs
from watching someone else do it and you
see them before and you're like yeah
obviously that makes sense of how fast
they're falling yeah yeah when you're
doing it you jump with a bungee jump
you're like oh my God like this is you
just feel like a rock yeah you you just
immediately plummet and it's such a
weird feeling the like kind of your body
weight just falling yeah it's so fun and
then when you sling up it's really fun
at this moment where I thought I had
like grown out of let's say thrill rides
and uh you know roller coasters and
stuff like that
um and then like I think I mean Sydney
just went on a date like a few months
ago to uh Tokyo dome which kind of have
which kind of has like a little like
theme park area and we were [__]
bored and we were like yeah let's let's
go on the [__] pirate ship you know
you know you know the [__] pirate
ship yeah yeah we were just like get out
let's [__] it let's go on it and just
like be kids again or whatever and we
started off just like you know like kind
of like taking the piss sarcastic they
get to be like whoa whoa we're on a
pirate ship and then when it get when it
gets [__] high I had forgotten the
feeling of like getting butterflies yeah
got a roller coaster and we both came
off with like the biggest [__] pure
smile on our faces it was like one of
the fair I've forgotten how much I had
like missed roller coaster and then we
went on like the Tokyo dome roller
coaster as well which I think like has
one of the biggest drops uh in Japan for
roller coaster and it's like
a cabs like I've forgotten the feeling
of just what it almost felt like Free
Falling and just kept going and going
and going and I'm like damn I miss going
to theme parks I want to go to fujiku
now I can't relate man yeah have you
just yeah when did like have you just
never been to roller coasters into
roller coasters never I I think I think
the problem was I went on a roller
coaster I went on like a roller coaster
in in Disney sea when I was like really
young right and that just like scarred
me for Life yeah I think like I just
don't think yeah I don't know I'm not
it's weird like it's not that I'm not
like a thrill seek or anything it's just
it's very like circumstantial as to what
kind of Thrills I like yeah and just
roller coasters just don't really do it
for me I don't know oh that's it's not
even that like I'm scared of them it's
just like it's not fun yeah I mean like
it's not something on my inside bucket
list go into theme parks that I guess
are actual theme parks are not like
thrill because like Disneyland like
Disneyland I prefer throw parks thrill
parks are like so much better I I just I
just don't understand
for some people it's very magical yeah
but we're better old men so I think I
think I'd rather just go to the movies I
think I'm just too British for that I am
too British dude I just can't when
someone's in like a full costume like I
think we said it's another thing like I
just can't
the thing is they're probably having the
time of their life sometimes or some of
these Disney actors absolutely [__]
love it yeah that's that's I'm happy for
them but for me I just can't
just put myself out although but I had
so much [__] fun in Nintendo land
that like
it was cool but I just wish there was
kind of more stuff yeah well that's
quite visually cool to look that's why
I'm excited because they're making that
new uh Donkey Kong area now all right so
I'm going to go back when that happens
but I think yeah just clearly they
should just open up a full Park and not
totally it would crash I mean the Ghibli
Park's opening up as well and you know
that's somewhere I want to go I think
that's what it is it's like it's not
that I don't like it's gonna they're
gonna have a ride where I mean is
disappointed in you yeah yeah it's gonna
be really fun all right so this is a
half troll answer okay go on then League
of Legends what about it okay you don't
want to do it anymore okay well
obviously I've tried it once I don't
want to do it again okay but it's it's
okay obviously haha League fans and
league players but I just think back to
how much time I put into learning a game
like League you know learning the
mechanics and you know you think about
out the barrier of entry about how much
time we have to put in to learn this
game the characters mechanics just to be
competent at it I cannot see myself
doing that ever again for like any other
game yeah just because I don't have that
I kind of wish I could go back and get
into League again yeah so fun when I got
into it yeah such a exciting thing and
it had such a cool premise it was just
really fun yeah because I I think back
and I think like the own like I could
have there is only one point in time I
could have gone into league and it was
the time that I did get into League
because I'll never have that much time
again when I was just in [__]
University had so much spare time and
just I could just grind out games and
just like really learn the game because
now I I just have this thing whenever
whenever I try a game because I'm not
like a [__] streamer so uh I try a
new hot game and by the time I get to
try it out everyone's already [__]
cracked at the game and I [__] suck
yeah yeah
I just get good gone
you're a bronze for a reason
actually I was gold actually I was gold
I was wrong
this means absolutely nothing to me did
you have you ever gotten like put like
so many hours into a video game that you
got cracked at it Joey or was it always
single player it was the best game you
ever think you like you're the game
you're best at yeah like multiplayer
like like online multiplayer yeah yeah
uh I was like in high school my friend
really got me into Starcraft
I I I play while everyone else around me
was playing League like me and my
friends were playing Starcraft I got
pretty good at it I did a rank in it or
I don't even remember but because it was
like it was such a it was like a very
condensed short amount of time like it
was there was a period I think for maybe
like like three or four months where I
was playing Star of like every [__]
day off to school yeah and then so so
maybe I got some rank uh up to that
point but it was such a short period of
time and it's a condensed period of time
that I just genuinely don't remember
yeah and uh yeah that's probably my
anti-bocker list too playing Starcraft
because uh they never again probably
never again you do oh I can't remember I
can't imagine you getting into Starcraft
actually I was into it and then at one
point I think I just hit a wall yeah
you're like the most anti-gamer gamer
yeah you just like I just I just don't
like playing I just want to chill and
play Kirby yeah totally it's like I I
just can't play casual like when there's
an option of casual or ranked I'm like
what's the point in playing casual
because I want to
yeah for me it's it's not relaxing to
play casual I'm like there's no Stakes
there's no kind of challenge yeah it
doesn't help me I don't want steaks is
there any sports you guys did before
that you uh like yeah uh rugby Fox rugby
yeah rugby I actually like rabies
football I hate it I hate to dream
football I like soccer no no Joe you're
in England you're in England Joey it's
[__] soccer in it because I was I was
always the goalie and I am for some
reason that checks out
[__] checks I was the only kid that
didn't mind just eating [__] and that is
literally the goalie's job
that's why it's so perfect for you I
don't know oh my God I was like I I was
like trying to imagine I cannot imagine
kind of playing football and as soon as
you mentioned Goldie I was like yeah
actually checked out I was always just
like I was always pretty athletic uh but
I just they were like all right we need
someone who doesn't mind jumping they're
putting their face first into someone's
feet and I was like all right I'll do it
uh I loved it uh and then they also
because it was always it was the UK so
it was always rainy and muddy yeah I
always you always got the most dirty it
was horrible yeah before every football
match because I was like so is this rank
door yeah
but then I happened to join uh when I
when I was they needed goalie and I I
think I was the only one like doing
goalie so yeah I'll be a goalie and my
dad was really happy that I was playing
in a football team he's like oh my God
that's my boy she's such a British man
yeah uh and um yeah it's happened to me
the one year where our team was cracked
it's like they were all they were all
very very good footballers and so I I
would play football we were in this
games and I would just be there for like
40 minutes doing nothing
just standing in the cold that wouldn't
even be warm because I'm just waiting
for them to the ball never came to our
side of the pitch right I'm like man
this sucks you're the easiest job ever
yeah it was the easiest job ever and
then I remember one time because I was
just zoned out because the ball never
came uh that the ball just came by and I
just completely ignored it it went in
because I was just standing there
because I just didn't I was like I was
like I was thinking about what what like
when I was gonna play video games later
I was like oh yeah and then I heard
they're like and I heard like Dude full
like started in front of me and went in
and I just wasn't paying attention I got
so much [__] for it an unbelievable
amount of [__] damn uh and I was like oh
yeah I forgot I have to do this job
sometimes yeah you literally just went
NPC mode yeah pretty much you went AFK
bro yeah I'm so bad at kicking it as
well so they I would always give it to
someone else to kick because I couldn't
kick the ball I'm so bad yeah I I would
just jump at it yeah did you have a
sport you played uh basketball I think
uh I think I think I briefly mentioned
this but I was on the basketball team in
school but a complete accident just
because they needed someone tall and I
just happened to be tall and uh would
you do it again
[Laughter]
yeah
I mean I was never really that good at
football
um but that's what I actually really
enjoyed was hockey I don't know why
um ice hockey or no just like
we have we have Canadians watching this
you can't say hockey they get really
offended if you refer to that as hockey
well they can they can have that [__]
ice hot gardening field hockey no I mean
hockey is just hockey guys right right I
mean [__] hockey guys you know the
sport in the Olympics guys come on we
had neither in Australia so yeah you had
AFL right yeah we had AFL I play AFL
again like rugby yeah but AFL was I
don't know AFL is better in my opinion
because I think I got hurt less in AFL
they're like AFL AFL was more tough
because there was way more running and
like kicking involved whereas rugby was
just like if you were a little skinny
Asian boy like I was then you would be
sensible you would be no you it was
always for me after you know during
school if we were doing like a rugby
game together in the in the schoolyard
it'd be like all right Joey you're the
skinniest and the fastest so you're
gonna be at the wing and I was just like
okay and the problem was was that it
would always come over to the wing and
then there'd just be these dudes who
were just like three times my size who
were like I'm going to [__] destroy
you yeah but there's no better feeling
than sprinting into someone and like
juking them yeah dude whenever I pull
off like a devil bat ghost I'm just like
it's just like let's go it was such a
rewarding fit I wanted to be toxic on
League of Legends I was like man if only
I could turn around and talk [__] to
this guy after I went past him
well the few times I did get hurt and uh
did get tackled I was just like yeah
never again
during the first time you as a kid that
you realize you could get hurt
uh as a kid I was pretty like fearless
and then that I remember I had one
injury that really scared me and I was
like oh oh it really hurts when you fall
or get hurt no I think I had that mint I
had the opposite mentality of like I was
such a [__] where I was just like I
don't want to do anything that
potentially gets me hurt and I think
that's why I avoided getting seriously
injured as a child but surely there must
have been a point where that taught you
pain right yeah because as a kid you're
pretty like yeah when my sister would
beat me off maybe
that's when you realize that's what I
realized like you know my brother and
sister like you know just [__]
bantering and then it would start a
fight and then someone would throw a
hand and then obviously the other one
would fight back and my sister was just
like no holds but I'm gonna [__] you up
I I gotta ask because you're younger
than you yeah she beat you up yes what
the [__] she totally beat me up she
she let out all the frustrations
yeah exactly exactly okay I gotta ask
because you know I I I don't get I never
got this experience as like an only
child but it seems like every time I
talk to someone who had siblings
um they just was like a moment in your
life where you went from like beating
the [__] out of each other just like I
kind of just like realizing one day
actually they're kind of [__] cool no
you always think that and it's like
you're when you're at home you just when
you're around people all that time you
just get angry but it's like it's like
if I was fighting my brother and someone
else tried to like punch him I would we
would both turn it's not like like I
think in your head you're thinking like
oh during childhood you hate each other
and then as adults you're caught no it
was literally every other day it would
change yeah it was like one morning you
would wake up and be like God my sibling
is an absolute [__] and then the next
day you'd be like nice they're the best
which is why it's like really cool in a
way that like because it I guess living
with like three other people your age
must be such a different Human
Experience to having yeah I feel I feel
Conor had a very different experience to
me because you you had three brothers
you're all three brothers and there was
a lot more of you guys right whereas I
only had a sister so well because I mean
I had to learn to share things and that
was I hated that
was like I I saved up for an Xbox yeah
and suddenly they wanna they wanna play
on it and I only get two hours of my
Xbox that doesn't feel fat but I had to
did you get how many Downs uh yeah of
course of course how many Downs are a
thing as well uh right which is pretty
wired terrible fashion since my entire
life because I was just used to wearing
what I was given yeah and I kept that
mentality going into adulthood and then
you become a YouTuber and then people
send you merch you're like all right
cool I just want to wear this the cycle
continues yeah
some Henry damage just in different
formats yeah yeah I mean you it's just
it's such a bizarre thing to think that
I I had that experience and Josh can't
you didn't and I'm like I couldn't
imagine did you did you did you what
like what was the point where you kind
of like start treating each other
I was like thinking about how to work
when you leave when you leave yeah why
do you leave yeah it's when both of you
leave your parents house or one of you
leaves and you come back you're like man
I actually kind of Miss yeah yeah
totally uh you know now that I don't see
my brothers all the time you know it's
I'm like man I wish I got to see them
more yeah yeah no totally
you are you never know what you don't
have uh what you haven't do you don't
have it but it's nice right absolutely
if you think about it it's like it's
like having like a almost like another
you who's experienced everything you've
experienced but slightly different yeah
and they're like really cool because
like I'm really I'm really obviously
I've already had a really good
relationship with my parents but it's
like it'd be cool to have it's cool that
I have someone who's like similar age as
well who's has the exact same kind of
experience yeah I don't know it's a
really weird way did you ever have a
point where you're like I [__] hate
this [__] you know I I I was like oh
totally 100 yeah yeah yeah absolutely
like I think it's more more often than
not you know especially while you're
growing up and you're still trying to
like you haven't even figured yeah you
haven't even figured yourself out at
that point let alone trying to
understand someone else as well like
especially one who is living with you
you know every day like that was tough
and like yeah we'd constantly get into
fights but then you know we would always
have this thing where it's like doesn't
matter how bad the fight was the next
day we were always chill about it like
we wake up and it was like there's
nothing happening well
your parents had to make you like makeup
oh yeah yeah like my dad was like I will
beat you up if you don't get back
together with your sister later
yeah I'll beat you up if you don't get
back with your sister
because I was like Dad this sounds good
yeah like I think I think the good thing
was was that uh my family was never a
family that would like hold garages or
anything so like no matter how bad the
fight was or no matter how bad the
quarrels might have been like the next
day it was always like no let's just
like you know we're still family at the
end of the day let's just leave that
behind us and you know yeah have a good
day yeah because it's always been weird
for me as like hearing about sibling
kind of like you know uh life uh because
I think the closest thing I have is my
cousins I think that's the reason I'm so
[__] close to most of my cousins
because I have a lot of my cousins are
only only children like me
um but like we have like I guess a
similar bond without going through all
the fighting that I hear that siblings
go through and I think that's just
because when we see each other
um you know there was only like a few
times that we would able you know I
actually when we were kids we hung out
quite a lot but we didn't have to see
each other every single day yeah uh yeah
I can't imagine how I can't imagine how
that is yeah so just just imagine like
you know uh like like just think of like
your I don't know if you have a favorite
cousin but like think think of your
favorite cousin and just imagine like
living with them every day for the first
20 years of your life yeah right that's
basically what it's like well the
sibling Dynamics kind of like accurate
is it just like is it like the youngest
one gets like the most spoiled on the
most attention
no I think it depends on the parents
I've like as as the oldest sibling was
it like did your parents look at you to
like look after your sister oh totally
okay yeah normally the oldest has the
most responsibility that's pretty yeah
it's like hey can you can you be can you
take care of them but I think it might I
think in my case it was a bit different
because I think if we had to compare
like who got spoiled more it might have
been my sister just because like she was
the daughter of the family right whereas
like oh Sydney definitely got the sport
the [__] status right yeah it's
always it's most of the time it's the
daughter that gets spoiled by the dad
right you know and uh and then the the
sun aka me would be like all right I'm
gonna whip you in a [__] [__]
no holds bar you though you're the one
doing the discipline I'm gonna make you
a man
how did that work out
um Dad I think you failed
so not exactly an anti-bucklist but uh
when did you guys start to realize
I just don't want to do [__] shots
again
I was like shots like a camera
um that is actually when you mature as a
human being yeah that's the peak
maturing point that might have happened
like
I don't know yeah because I I I'm trying
to remember the exact moment when I
thought shots means I'm gonna have a
good night versus shots mean I'm gonna
have a [__] terrible time because
anyone is confused for whatever reason
can't talk about alcoholic shots yeah I
think I think maybe when I was like
definitely early 20s for me was when
it's still like 23 24 I think when I
moved to Japan yeah 100 Japan I was like
yeah I think I just don't want to do
shots anymore like there's no occasion
and now I I pretty much do everything in
my power to avoid it yeah yeah yeah and
even sometimes if I'm given a shot and
there's like a can of something else
nearby that's near amputee I'll be like
oh thanks guys okay that's why I don't
like drinking with Americans because so
many of them it doesn't matter how old
they are they just like let's do [__]
tequila shots and I'm just like no I do
not read single person hold on is it
your American impression yeah what the
[__] is that that's a valley girl
impression who are you having drinks
with joy [__] mailing
every time I'm drinking with mainly
she's like Joey I think you should do a
tequila shot and I'm just like [__] off
mainly I don't want I don't even like
tequila no one likes to kill her except
Americans do Americans do yeah yeah it's
weird because I remember did you did you
ever you know in in Australia did you
have ring of fire at all was that it was
that a good call or something else we
called it something else though right
[__] what do we call it I know what
you're talking about though yeah so Ring
of Fire is I think like a staple of like
every at least British uni where you
have like a pint in the middle which is
called the Dirty pint uh and then you
have a bunch of cards around that point
uh and you pick up a different card and
different cards
at once I don't think we have not at
least not like Ring of Fire
um because I remember like the word like
the the one experience that I was like
I'm never playing ring of fire again was
uh we for some reason we this was like
[__] uh at midnight so we already had
a few drinks and uh we thought oh
[__] dirty Point that's too boring
you know alcohol that's too boring let's
spice things up and uh We've started
putting some [__] uh like [__] like
hot sauce and like washing up Liquid in
there washing up like washing up
yeah this was [__] somebody drink
washing up Liquid yeah I did I lost and
how are you alive sorry yeah yeah that
like kill you that's like bleach uh yeah
I I was I was a [__] dumbass kid yeah
this I was a [__] dumbass kid I was
18 years old generally you threw it up
instantly yeah I did throw it up
instantly why would you risk your life
with that this is this is this is why
people when they're like man I don't
drink camera too yeah yes please do it
for the cloud you know
yeah and I I just think about some of
the [__] stupid [__] I did back in
the day and uh and now yeah hopefully
hopefully we're more mature right
hopefully I haven't well I haven't seen
you drink washing up Liquid so I feel
like you're more mature slightly no yeah
luckily I survived that to uh never do
that again what's the dumbest thing
you've done during like a drinking
session yours is washing up yeah we used
to do that too we used to have a rule
where you could put anything in the in
the cabinets in it oh [__] so people
would put stuff like
um cooking oil oh you could ingest but
you couldn't keep it down that's like a
tear down
she's the average American diet nearly
Beast drank like three liters of that
[__] and yeah yeah exactly exactly
by the way when I say washing up Liquid
it was it was unlike a few drops
it was normal right but I don't want
people to think they just want friends
that's putting like a tide pot on the
corner of the glass and being like wow
look at the garnish I think the dumbest
thing I did was um like it involves
tequila another reason why I hate to
kill but like you know a normal to kill
a shot for those of you who don't know
because you'd pour the salt you know on
your hand where it was somewhere on your
hand right and then you'd have a lemon
in the other hand and you you'd lick the
salt you do the shot and then you eat
the lemon right that's that's the
standard tequila shot uh we did this
thing called uh what is called a
kamikaze shot which is essentially the
same thing it's the salt and the lemon
and the tequila shot but what you do is
you snort the salt you take this shot
and then you pour the lemon in your eye
that's the point of that uh just seeing
someone else do it that's not you is
[__] hilarious
as being stupid then I've done plenty of
those yeah never again
chewy is just unhygienic it's not like
yeah it's just gross yeah it's just
gross because like you know you like
every time I talk to someone from
Australia or England or Europe everyone
has like everyone has that one drink
right it's it's the first drink you
learned that uh you drunk too much of
and then you threw up and then you can
it's like a core memory now you know
what I mean it's like every time you
smell that drink you're like no I can't
do it that's wrong for me is that wrong
yeah oh which sucks because it's like I
actually like a lot of rum drinks but
the moment I smell any kind of ram I'm
just like I'm reminded of those
traumatic experiences can't drink them
for me it's a for me it's something I
remember uh I remember this was uh I
think about a New Year's Eve party with
my cousins this book is so gross yeah I
mean it is it is gross so nice and I
remember at the time I thought it was uh
like pretty nice tasting because I was
like oh it's like a sweet shot it's not
nothing like nothing like a vodka shot
or a whiskey shot it's actually got a
bit of flavor to it uh I guess yeah I
mean that's that's all right
yeah yeah he was he was I mean let's
let's say it was a step up from washing
up Liquid okay
I think anything
oh
it's clear that's how it works I think
it works okay I'm getting this cool
memory back because I think I think it
uh traumatized me over two things okay
because apparently what I did I didn't I
didn't actually throw up because I tried
because my my all of our parents were in
like the other room and it was just like
us cousins like getting like shit-faced
drunk yeah uh so I tried my best to
basically like sober up right so what I
did was there was no food in the
cupboard except for a few loaves of
Hovis bread
I just sat there for about three hours
just like nibbling on this bread finish
one loaf [__] God I started another
loaf of bread
I went through two loaves of bread the
entire impressive amount of bread
together and then it was only after I
finished the second where I was like I
can't hold anything anymore is this why
you don't like breath I'm thinking maybe
I was like [__] I completely forgot this
happened but may maybe this experience
just traumatized me on every single
types of bread as well just washing up
like it you can get multi-organ failure
following a large ingestion well uh wow
but it would cause you nausea and
vomiting yeah because you most certainly
would vomit yeah yeah God damn why what
is with what is with kids I'm not being
dumb yeah uh that's why I like you know
I grew out of that phase very quickly I
think because I mean the moment you're
like throwing up and having horrible
time I think is when you you kind of
realize you're like is this fun this is
not fun I don't think fitting in is fun
yeah yeah have you guys ever been like
blackout drunk oh yeah of course I've
had like that's only happened to me once
and that like terrified me enough to
like never want to like do it again yeah
I mean it's all it's all a learning
experience that's again that's another
reason why I don't drink tequila anymore
alcohol is uh is in in moderation can be
great and a fun time yeah and you know I
think again anyone who any anytime I
meet someone like I don't drink I'm like
you're so smart yeah yeah
actually respect yeah uh even more
respect to people who have decided to
stop drinking yeah yeah I know a few of
as well yeah yeah I think it's it's good
I'm definitely drinking less uh as I'm
getting older that's for sure like so I
feel like eventually I'm gonna get to
that point where I'm just like you know
what I think I'm good yeah I think it's
smart
um yeah I mean obviously if you drink
especially if you're raised in the kind
of like the British Australian culture
you'll have gone you know well you're
kind of encouraged to get smashed yeah
yeah especially in University uh yeah
definitely I mean I have like a tiny
little scar because I blacked out one
time and I don't know what happened like
uh yeah I think I told the story of the
podcast no I don't think so so I went we
had this game I I swear I've told the
story we have this game where you'd have
like four cups like this like four like
if you mentioned like orange juice
glasses yeah like this you'd line them
up one two three four uh and then if you
can imagine there's like a little
there'd be a little Gap in the middle
right so you'd all take it in turns
flicking coins in which now is also just
a dirty thought to think that we're
putting
you have to flick coins in they don't
have a shot of vodka each in them oh uh
and you'd all you did before of you
sitting uh on each side of the table
yeah and so you'd flick a coin in
and if you've got it in one and then
Joey you also didn't get it in you would
have to drink it with the coins inside
of it uh well you would drink the coin
you'd take you'd kind of drink it and
then get the coin out yeah yeah I know I
know I know you're a [__] Universe
yeah of course of course uh and I I
these are people who I just moved in
with and I really wanted to be accepted
by them so I was like yeah
so what ended up happening was that if
you if you get it in uh the another
glass as well the next person if they
don't get it M1 has to do two oh [__]
and I can keep going but there's another
thing where if you get it in between all
of them uh you have to do all of them
yeah if someone doesn't then and so I
had that I had to drink all four of them
all these shots which were very generous
shots yeah the vodka and I was like oh
God okay then I lost again in the middle
so I ended up doing like like 10 shots
it's four but they were definitely big
yeah yeah ridiculous amount of shots
back to back and then everyone's like
yeah let's go out to the club now and
then I just do not remember but
apparently I went
and then I woke up the next day I was
like [__] my head hurts then I woke up
and there's just blood on my wall and
blood all over my room what blood all
over my bed and then I look in the
mirror and my like my eyes completely
swollen over yeah so I must have just
[__] face planted at some point yeah
on the ground and hit concrete uh cut
open my my uh but my head there she's
very lucky that it was just like there
right here not my eye yeah uh yeah and
then I got trying a little scar now you
can't see it uh but yeah so that was the
first time and uh hopefully it'll last
yeah it's uh it's yeah I think I like a
similar
instance in University there's nothing
more terrifying peer pressure is a very
powerful thing it is it is it is a very
powerful thing uh which we can say now
as adults uh [__] overrated you guys
are better than that yeah
um Tomatoes nothing more terrifying than
opening my eyes and just not recognizing
my immediate surrounding yeah oh yeah
I've been there yeah yeah you know it's
funny like even even if you like even if
I sleep over at a friend's place I I I
miss my bed too much yeah and I hate I
always dread the feeling of like waking
up and I'm just like where the [__] am I
yeah no matter how drunk I am I'm using
100 of my remaining brain power to be
like I'm gonna make it back to this bed
like no matter what like I I could be so
I could be like just incoherent like you
can't even like understand what I'm
saying but in my head I'm just like bed
now I'll get there I I've had moments in
my life where I have uh barely been you
know conscious drunk you know that kind
of like [__] stupid ass drunk and
somehow there is one part of my brain
that is like a [__] uh messenger
pigeon like it it has like built-in GPS
to like be able to walk me home no
matter where I am and I'm just like how
the [__] can I do this yeah you know
it's not my story but my favorite
blackout story is from one of my friends
in Japan uh he was out drinking in like
shibio Shinjuku or somewhere uh like few
years ago and like just got absolutely
like destroyed like he was like so drunk
but he somehow he was lit it was he was
drinking kind of close to where he was
living right yeah in this apartment so
he's like okay well I'm not gonna have a
problem like walking home like I know
where I am uh but the problem was that
because it's an apartment you know all
the doors look the same right so what so
what he thought was his own house that
he walked into uh turned out to be the
exact same like room number but on the
floor below oh [__] and and at the time
he thought he was like oh it's really
weird that this door is just like open
like did I just like forget to unlock
this door because it does like no key
was involved like he just opened the
door right oh and he only found out that
he was in the wrong apartment because he
woke up and you know like just on the
floor of this apartment that he thought
was his and he just looked over and
basically where you were sitting where
you're sitting right now got there was
just like a pig
oh because apparently the neighbor
downstairs in secret was owning this pet
pig that's some [__] hangover yeah
lock his door if he has an illegal Pig
in there yeah and then apparently like
he was like he just looked over he saw
this pig and he was like oh God I'm in
the wrong apartment and then right on
cue the owner of that apartment came out
of his bedroom and he was like the [__]
are you doing
well good thing he's uh he wasn't in
America oh my God imagine I had a friend
one time who told me about uh he got
really drunk uh and when he was walking
home and like I guess he just fell
asleep walking home yeah and uh
apparently he woke up and he was in a
building and they were housing like
refugees in the building and the
refugees saw him on the ground and like
brought him in and like shed their like
floor space holy [__] and he was like
what the [__] woke up and he and
apparently he added them on Facebook and
they like keep in touch sometimes still
because they were super chill about it
they were like very helpful that's so
funny uh but that must have been a
bizarre a bizarre experience he just
woke up and you're surrounded by Ricky
she's like trying to help you yeah
you're like what the heck where am I God
that's a [__] wild story I'm sure he
could tell the story much better he told
me that in full detail but that was the
only part I really remember it sounded
like [__] insane it was like what
yeah yeah I mean [__] you know I'm
glad I'm glad we're not that stupid
anymore hopefully hopefully well that's
that's part of being an adult you know
you get older you get smarter you don't
do that stuff anymore yeah and you
realize it's not worth it yeah yeah well
it's just sort of just you realize it's
not that fun you also like fun is so
relative and for some reason people
think that's cool and fun to do and
you're like actually it's kind of
[__] boring sure yeah I mean I think
I've realized I think when I realized
that hangovers actually affected me for
like more than one day was was when I
[__] you know what I mean you know what
I mean
they hang over could you when was the
last time you guys stayed up all night
what are you gonna stay up all night
stayed up all night 24 hour 24 hours in
ages yeah yeah because even the thing I
couldn't do at all show do you remember
back in the day when it was like you
just got really into a video game and it
was really easy
when I discovered Terraria so many
nights I would never just stay up 24
hours I would always go to bed at some
point even if it was like one hour
really I really couldn't do it yeah oh I
I did it so many times when I was in uni
yeah it would get to six and I was like
well
she got at least two hours in well
sometimes you just need like one more
League game and it's just like one more
League I want to end on a win and then
you're like [__] seven wins but then
you end on a win and then you're like
actually gotta I gotta keep playing till
I lose
yeah yeah yeah exactly no I mean like I
I can still like stay up all night it's
really weird because there's something
in my brain that just allows me to like
stay up as late as I want but as soon as
I go to bed like it I I pay the I pay
like the tax you know that's why I'm
always like the last one up but you will
never see me the next day because I am
like unfunctional I think that's my
problem is that like now I've done it
enough times and I know the limits of my
own body and mind where like fully
respectable yeah if I if I think to
myself okay it's like already three in
the morning uh which is already past my
bedtime yeah I could just stay up like I
I physically would be able to do it but
at what cost yeah you know and when I
think about that I'm like the cost is
not worth it I'd rather just go to bed
yeah yeah I like sleeping too much so we
talked about it's so [__] good yeah
yeah so we talked about our anti-bucket
list is there anything on your actual
bucket list would you okay here's the
thing we've talked about the Seven
Wonders do you think you'd actually want
to go to the Seven Wonders
only what I want to go to is Machu
Picchu why why do you have an obsession
with Machu pics you always bring it up
okay okay for one you brought up Machu
pitcher at least three times okay for
one okay a number of things
for one I [__] love hiking right so
it'd just be dope as [__] to go hiking
in the mountains yeah two it's like the
only real reason I would want to like
visit South America
[Music]
no offense to South America but it's
like I don't have like the biggest like
uh you know uh interest in a lot of like
South America just personally maybe I
just don't know about it I don't know
but the one thing that I think would
just be really cool to do is to like go
to Machu Picchu and also like I know a
lot of friends who've been to Machu
Picchu and they say like just Peru in
general is just like a really dope
country to like just go and like explore
obviously dangerous but my favorite
thing to do is whenever I mention I want
to go to a South American country I'd be
like no I want to get a I want to check
out Mexico and everyone from Mexico will
come out of the woodwork in my like live
stream chat and they'll be like don't
[Music]
if I mentioned Brazil everyone from
Brazil it's like no yeah that's yeah
that's the other problem is that like
whenever bring up like a South American
country that I would hear from someone
who'd be like oh it's like for example
like my friends Mexico for example like
you know a friend of mine like uh worked
in Colombia for like three months uh
earlier this year and he said it was
really [__] dope and I was like okay
cool that would be really you know if
you said it was cool then you know I
would be interested in I saw the photos
and everything it looks really cool yeah
but then when I hit up my friend who is
Brazilian who lives in Japan they were
just like yeah don't it's not worth it
so I'm like which one is it I want to go
but you guys are telling me not to go
it's like that thing when you live in a
place you kind of you're always dogging
on it because you're like there's always
better stuff elsewhere yeah if you don't
appreciate the good stuff about being
there for sure for sure
um would you guys want to go to would
you want to go to something I like the
idea of going to South America but every
time like I've had similar experiences
so yeah anyone living in South America
do you have any recommendations on where
actually you'd recommend yeah what's a
country you would actually recommend or
just a place where's the place you
recommend they're going to say Machu
Picchu that's not much man that that'll
be sad if like the top things to do in
South America Machu Picchu or nothing
else
I [__] in the photos yeah
um what about like uh like a Caribbean
country I would like to go to a
Caribbean I would like to go to
Caribbean I want to go to Jamaica that
would be a lot of fun it just seems fun
yeah Jamaica yeah Caribbean seems
awesome yes yeah Caribbean countries
will be dope I mean like I also want to
go to like less beachy places as well
because I feel like you know I've been
to like Thailand enough times and I'm
not going to compare Thailand like
Inland countries you mean yeah I I
really want to see them all landlocked
yeah no I wanna like maybe you want to
go like
Joey I don't know there's a club I found
on Reddit that was like apparently it
was titled like uh Mongolian traditional
dish being prepared and it's just like a
guy smacking an ass cheek and it was
just air coming out of the ash cheek I
don't I don't I want to go I don't know
what the [__] it was but it had me
giggling because it just looks
ridiculous
it looked absurd yeah I want to see the
Northern Lights before yeah yeah yeah
I've never seen the Northern Lights
um yeah I mean I'm Southeast Asian so
when we went on holidays we would avoid
cold countries like the [__] plague
we're like oh we do we are not built for
this climate we did not survive Here and
Now That I'm Older I'm like yeah kind of
a Vibe is it because
you guys didn't have like the winter
clothes yeah pretty much is it you just
like you're like this is not worth
investing in a whole set of clothes do
you know how expensive winter jackets
are Jesus Christ
yo everything everything I bought was
like the you know you got hand-me-downs
I got like everything I bought was a
second hand from the [__] car boot
sale that was that was my fashion winter
jacket from a car boot shop it's
probably better than the Primark because
I don't remember they sell winter
jackets yeah does not sell winter
jackets
okay there's like winter jackets and
then there's like you know for British
Winters and then there is winter jackets
for if you're actually going to go
skiing or to an actual [__] country
like skiing you need some some like yeah
that's specialized gear because you need
like [__] that can roll in the snow can
get like a bunch of wind chill because
you're going fast like that's different
I mean if you go to a cold place
um it won't feel as cold as when you're
skiing because how what you're doing
it's just very different okay because
I've gone to cold places before and not
needed the winter jacket because it's
like oh you're [__] marriage I think
I think what I want to do now that I've
done quite a bit of traveling and I want
to definitely do more traveling is like
I just want to go to countries or places
that are kind of unconventional to go to
in terms of like tourism or like you
know like a country where like you would
never hear of anyone actually going to
places like that you know why do you
want to do that I don't know just
because I know so little about it and I
don't I know barely any anecdotes of
people going to those places and I'm
just I just want to figure out for
myself really just me and it's awesome
maybe not an alternative but yeah you
can go to North Korea you know I'm good
I'll stick to South Korea I'll stick to
South Korea well like you know like for
example like I wanna you know like I've
always said like I've always wanted to
like go to Antarctica or like Greenland
or like nothing to do in Antarctica well
I don't know
I can tell you I do know there is
I want to do that though because how
many people do you know other than most
stories that has been so Antarctica you
know like I don't know I feel like the
problem is at that point when you go to
Antarctica like how much the beach did
it yeah everything you're doing is is
you I had a guy who is an expert at this
is just is like toddlering you right
yeah he is doing everything for you know
at that point it's like you're not
really getting that experience and it's
like when people like climb Everest it's
like yeah because the [__] Sherpa is
carrying your ass all right you'd never
be able to do this alone yeah yeah it's
like are you really that sense of
accomplishment it's like did you really
do it or there's a [__] Sherpa who's
the goat who [__] save your ass did
this for you yeah yeah you've definitely
did some of it and I think it's still
valid you [__] climb this mountain or
whatever but yeah that's like I think
when you say like I want to go to
Antarctica I'm like man I just that
doesn't make any sense to me it's like
because you just you're not doing
anything you're some guy's taking care
of you yeah but I just I I just you know
I'm one of those people yeah I'm one of
those people that really values just
having that experience you know like
whether it is like something that was
like purely as you know because of my
actions and my actions alone it's just
the fact that it's just a cool story you
can tell you know like so like
Madagascar is another one where I'm just
like I just want to [__] go just to
see what it's like yeah or like you know
you see Prince Julian yeah I can see I
want to know if the animals are still
there you know is the zebra still there
I want to find out yeah I mean I I don't
know this is you know definitely
privileged to say but I just like
Comfort
unfortunately listen
I cannot shoot comfortably that's yeah
that's like a that's a big takeaway yeah
like I know some people you know like
you know go into third world countries
just to appreciate all of the things
that they have
um I do appreciate that and I'm gonna
continue appreciating but I appreciate
it if I said this I would get I would
get castrated by our audience okay
because appreciate it but only through
YouTube videos here's the thing the
reason I appreciate it is because I
haven't exactly been to a third world
country but I've been in the countryside
of Thailand which is like second world
country right it's not exactly you know
third world but I have stayed at some of
my family's places deep in the
countryside of Thailand where there's
[__] nothing to do there you [__] in
a Hole uh there is no flushable toilets
or anything like that and I'm like yeah
I like Comfort I do I do guys I do I I
very much I very much appreciate the
Comforts that I have and I'm going to
continue appreciating that I am luckily
privileged into like my confidence you
know I I don't look for a lot of things
I just want a nice bed I've slept on a
hard floor for like when you know being
a monk I I've I've done the [__] monk
life it's [__] great it's spiritual
you can learn a lot of things I like
having a bad guys yeah I mean
realistically I'm insane but like
realistic quickly I I also don't think I
could just like you know go to a third
world country just like immediately like
that without I think it would be a lot
easier in in my case personally if like
I I kind of went step by step you know
like you know like obviously you know
first of all and then like you know
experience a bunch of Second World
countries and like the way that they
live and the way that they like you know
spend their lives and then you know and
then progressively go down to the
thought like I don't think I could just
like [__] go to I thought you said
talk about like it's like like a like a
hot side of the pool so I gotta dip my
toes yeah yeah and then I gotta go fully
dude like as a child you couldn't just
like jump into the deep end that [__]
was scary you know you had to wean
yourself into it what blows mom out of
these people who go to these like crazy
dangerous countries yeah yeah see I
can't do that I've almost seen this guy
I don't know what he was but he just
like kept getting stopped at like
military checkpoints but they were like
militia and they were just taking his
passport and stuff and he was like do I
get it back and he's like wait and it's
like oh my God yeah I never want to be
in a situation
I'm very open to like having new
experiences in my life but you know if I
go to a place I do want there to be you
know the basic infrastructure of stuff
that I am kind of like familiar with
yeah why are you laughing
UK is a second world country because
they have the lack of yes yeah they
don't got [__] yeah
um I just want a good place to have a
nice meal as well that I could look
forward to that's all that's this list
of countries is Ever Ever Getting yeah
America Europe and some Asian countries
yeah I mean you know I uh I'm I'm happy
I'm comfortable I'm comfortable but uh I
certainly I I've done enough traveling
I've put myself in enough experiences to
know what I am cool not experiencing you
know that's fair that's fair tries to
avoid cancer life
no no I think that's I think that's
exactly it's valid it's one of those
things where like you have to be careful
how you say stuff like that right
because obviously it can come up with
just being at elitist or just being like
[__] those guys but I get it I think you
said it great though yeah yeah totally
yeah I'm not trying to come off as
though I know yeah yeah I mean there's
nothing wrong with wanting to be
comfortable anyone who's anyone who's
ever like who's looks like me and goes
and sees a stand a standing toilet I'm
like hell no and that's not even like
bad by like a lot of Standards right
that's pretty like normal so what are
you complaining about at least there's a
toilet yeah yeah
a lot of I know [__] a lot of British
people who wouldn't [__] dare [__] in
a standing toilet hell no I'll hold it
no yeah no I think I think I think every
person is allowed to have you know their
standards for travel and you know I
think there's no real like reason to be
judgmental about that because that's
that's on them I don't think you
actually stand while you [__] in that I
know that you you yeah I'm just going
like release
do you know okay because I think
sometimes it's just like the simple
things do you know what it was so when I
became a monk right I think the hardest
like period of that was like the first
week where you either like fully commit
or it just kind of like breaks you and
you're just like no I won't Comfort my
life you know like the thing that like
got me this close to my breaking points
cold showers
you get used to them pretty quickly I've
never done it but apparently you can you
get adjusted to it
I never did I know no I got adjusted to
sleeping on a concrete floor actually uh
without a pillow that was that actually
you know that was yeah something that I
just do pretty quickly uh I never got
used to coach owls now that was like
yeah if I was a monk I would I would
quit after three days and then just
chill out in the city for a few months
then come back to my family like dude it
was crazy it was so fun it's uh yeah the
whole uh the whole praying part was
really sick
uh yeah like it was it for me it was
like cold showers if I if I go to a
place and we had one place in our
America Tour that had a broken shower as
well that wasn't just broken that was
like a horror shower yeah it was and I
don't know if we said this on the
episode but like it was on the fourth
floor of a building that had no elevator
and the every single thing it was in LA
every single floor you go higher it got
more derelict and like dirt fresh and
the floor with the shower was had
cobwebs everywhere no light yeah no
light bulbs yeah and when you get in the
shower room it's just this small
concrete little Alleyway that's like
narrowing towards the shower it's really
creepy and then just a military like bed
propped up on the side of the wall and
you go in the shower and it's [__]
freezing yeah dribbling yep and so
you're like in this [__] cold ass
dribbling shower and then you want to
get out of it and you can't even dry
yourself properly because the floor is
so dirty and you can't step out because
it's gonna [__] matter or anything it
was horrible yeah yeah this is this is
one of the most expensive cities in the
world I remember I just took one look
and I was just like yeah I'm just gonna
stay smelly like I don't care yeah I
don't know why I was like I have to
shower yeah I regret it so much [__] uh
that was the moment that almost like I'm
never touring again like this really
yeah yeah I had a [__] that broke me
yeah that actually broke me that shower
I was like I actually actually made me
want to not tour anymore I'm done yeah
which is uh which you know you know
that's at the time uh it almost broke
but it didn't break us because we did
the Europe tour yeah no cold showers in
the Europe the showers in the Europe
tour were great yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly it was great so that's all I
need just give me like a nice hot shower
get my day started that's why okay
here's the thing uh uh I don't know if
we've told the story but when we did our
Japan road trip it was either me or manu
that was always late to every to
everything and the reason is we
I needed a shower to wake up that was
like why can't you take short showers
gone because this you need you can't
just have a short shower you you
actually just do it out I can do a one
minute shower I could be in and out 60
seconds that doesn't count that doesn't
count you know what you know when you
you can get clean you know you know when
you uh soap applies you know when it's
not about getting clean
it's not about it literally about
getting it is
actually just about getting that is why
we shower that is okay that is why we
shall that is one of the reasons that's
not the like the only reason that's
that's the reason why I take shelves
before I go to bed so that I can take my
time with my shower if I needed to have
a shower in the morning it's always
going to be quick I literally not a 40
second shower I think today oh my God I
can't imagine no no no no you couldn't
be me oh 40 seconds I think I ran the
shower longer to heat it up than I was
actually in it oh I literally sped on it
I was like water armpits soap full full
course done you wake up first thing and
you're just like you just let the water
run and you're just like all right
you're just getting ready for the day
there was like there was like six of us
waiting to use one shower and God's like
well God's gone in all right guys we'll
give up on a shower I mean I I could ask
you what's the point of taking a bath
baths are just less efficient showers
yeah I completely agree with you they're
gone and I'll do that if I have the time
which is the key factor here which we
did not have the time on the Japan
special yeah the other thing that pissed
us off during the Japan trip was not the
fact that you were taking long showers
it was the fact that it was like okay so
meeting at the lobby we're gonna leave
early it's like 8 30 you know 8 30 meet
up at the lobby and God's like perfect
I'll start my shower at 8 30. okay so I
was getting to this so you should never
room me with Manu ever again because we
have like the same mentality because I
was like the reason I'm starting my
shower at 8 30 was because Maddie was
taking a 15 minute shower I'm gonna call
gone out out of all three of us God is
always late to everything yeah now he's
on his own time zone
I don't know uh difference just average
15 minutes [__] hell that's a that's
a four course that makes sense mine mine
is roughly 10 to 15. I normally do five
five I'm like 10 minutes okay anyway
gone is always late to everything uh no
it's not like super late it'll gone will
just always be five or ten minutes
consistently five to ten minutes late to
everything why are you never on time
gone what's your reason it's because I
need those showers in the morning no you
can't always use this excuse me
or something
we all make a joke that we're like
whatever the time is talgon it 15
minutes earlier so that gaunt shows up
on time
we've done this a few times
where it's like okay uh so 11 at the
office tomorrow right it's like okay
great it's like all right Nabi tell gone
to meet at 10 45. and then you get there
at 11. it's funny like I like I'm more
likely to be on time if I have to like
travel far to a place yes I know this I
know this yeah I've noticed this about
you if it's if I'm like really close to
a place or if I know I can get there at
any time something my brain's just like
no I understand yeah yeah I get that but
but when I have to like schedule it out
I'm like okay I need to be there [__]
half an hour early yeah but what annoys
us the most is like say we're meeting up
at the the office at 11 right and then
you know Conor I will like text the
group being like God where you at and
then you'd be like I'm getting ready and
I'm like when we said 11. we don't mean
start getting ready at 11. we mean get
your ass here by 11. okay so normally on
office days I I do have like that 10
o'clock meeting uh which might might
have played like a big factor yeah but I
was like I'll be honest guys I'm I'm
trying to like uh if if do this
efficiently for me this is this is a me
thing I'm like it's absolutely so we all
have to have like weekly Geeks plus
meetings and I'm like let's do it like
an hour before a trash Chase meeting you
know the boys will understand you know
I'm I'm trying to do this
[Music]
but I stick my I stick by the showers
okay I'm like that I'm like you know I'm
like a [__] Windows computer that
doesn't have like an SD drive you know I
I you switch it on and he needs like 15
like 5-15 minutes in the shower just
like food up you say SD drive uh
I'm on like the old [__] hard drives
you know the [__] mechanical ones I'm
like really loud ones how do you just
like see like the Windows XP logo and
you're like all right you need a bit of
time to wake up to get the day started
sharing for less than five minutes may
not be long enough to cleanse your body
I'm not saying it's ideal but if you got
to do it you got to do it all right
because let's be honest we're just
trying to get rid of the stink markers
obviously with a dirty you know what I
mean but like a lot of times I'm just
trying to get rid of the smell of you
you know so yeah but it's 40 seconds
enough to get rid of the smell I think
if you show up
listen I I would love a shower but
sometimes you have to do a one minute
shower no because I shower before I go
to bed like a comment like like a sane
post I can't win I can't win can I I
give a reasonable rationale as to why
you might have to do a shortage I think
all the time I want I'm going to bed
I'm not gonna be like [__] I need to go
to bed 40 seconds in the shower no
longer I just want to get a gold split
sometimes okay I just wanna I need to be
in bed on the dot I'm I'm gonna do my
name am I getting my new goal in life is
to do the quickest possible shower I
need a time let's just Speed Run yeah
it's literally it's literally from the
moment you step in it's like how quickly
can I do it
pre-surping must not be allowed right
that's true yeah just shower 80 no skips
also got to be with us with a block of
syrup says that just seems more exciting
that that could definitely be a speed
running dropping the soap is
that's a run dude I can't wait for the
summoning salt video
all right but uh that has been this
episode of trash taste God I can't wait
which uh which shower which shower are
you are you a Connor are you a Joey or
are you a gaunt
um I like launcher I just don't have no
I'm not gonna no no let's not get into
it don't do the thing all right hey look
at these patrons though I'm sure uh they
shower for enough time
ain't no way oh [__] you're right
they're anime fans too
but uh Hey if you like to join the uh
show and uh support us then go on over
to our patreon patreon.com trash taste
also follow us on Twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
her face listen to us on Spotify and uh
we will we'll be back in the regular
studio after this one so we'll see you
guys back at home bye guys
[Music]
foreign